Indeed, it is awesome. But, how does this affect performance?
>> Well. Note the sequence of steps here. When we encounter
the script tag, we have to pause DOM construction and let JavaScript
run before we could continue. JavaScript is said to be. Parser
blocking, because it blocks, DOM construction when we encounter the script tag.
>> I see, but that doesn't seem like that big of a deal.
JavaScript is pretty fast, right?
>> It is, but, let me make a slight modification. Instead
of using an inline script, like what we have here on the
bottom. Let's say, we move the script content into an external file.
Like, what we have here. What would you expect to happen now?
>> Hm, well, same as before, the parser finds the script
tag, fetches the file and executes it. Oh wait, oh, I see.
This fetch could take awhile, right? And while
the browser's fetching this file, the browser's blocked
and can't continue constructing the DOM. Which would
in turn, slow down the critical rendering path.
>> Exactly. The script tag blocks the parser from proceeding, and
we're stuck waiting, [SOUND] for this file. Not a good outcome.
>> So, if external JavaScript always blocks the parser, it
sounds like I should just inline all of my JavaScript.
>> Well, yes and no. You're right in that,
inlining the JavaScript would help limit the requests. But, there's
some downsides as well. For example, if you use the
same code on multiple pages, then that will be redundant
code in all those pages. So there are tradeoffs here.
>> All right. But, for code that's specific to
one page, that seems like a pretty good strategy. Yeah,
that's reasonable. But, let's take a look at some
of the tradeoffs and the gotchas word associated with them.